I DON'T THINK SO.
>> Tucker: YEP, HATE THE
COUNTRY, TRYING TO DEGRADE IT
AND IT'S WORKING.
THE HEADLINE HERE IS THAT THE
WHITES OF PREMISES AND THE BIDEN
WHITE HOUSE IS SO INTENT, 21
BLACK STAFFERS -- CAN THERE BE
MORE THAN 21 TOTAL?
NOT A HUGE STAFF OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
21 BLACK STAFFERS HAVE FLED.
SPEAKING OF THE NEW JIM CROW.
CANDACE OWENS IS THE FOUNDER OF
THE CHARITY, PROBABLY NOT
SURPRISED BY THIS.
ARE YOU SURPRISED AT THE RACISM,
THE WHITE SUPREMACY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE IS SO INTENSE THAT
BLACK STAFFERS ARE FLEEING FOR
THEIR LIVES?
>> I HAVE TO SAY I'M A LITTLE
BIT UPSET THAT I'M NOT INVOLVED
IN THESE STRATEGY SESSIONS OF
THE WHITE HOUSE.
I JUST PICTURE THEM ALL SITTING
AROUND A TABLE JUST QUICK,
QUICK, BLACK PEOPLE ARE WAKING
UP AND THEY ARE NOT HAPPY,
GRABBED ME AND ASIAN AND PUT HIM
IN FRONT OF THE PODIUM, WITH GOT
TO SHIFT HERE AND SHIFT GEARS
COMPLETELY AS A P.R. STRATEGY.
THIS IS ACTUALLY WHAT THEY ARE
DOING, RIGHT?
BLACK AMERICANS -- FIRST AND
FOREMOST, WHAT'S HAPPENING FIRST
AND FOREMOST IS THEY ARE WAKING
UP TO BLACK LIVES MATTER.
YOU HAVE THESE BLACK AMERICANS
THAT WERE QUITE LITERALLY JUST
GIVEN THESE CONDITIONS, THEY
WEREN'T MEANT TO DO ANYTHING,
THEY NEVER WANTED THEM TO
ACTUALLY DO ANYTHING, THEY
PROBABLY WERE UNDERQUALIFIED FOR
THE POSITIONS THAT THEY EVEN HAD
BUT THE IDEA WAS WHAT, WHERE
GETTING ON HER KNEES LITERALLY
IF YOU'RE NANCY PELOSI, TO THE
BLACK LIVES MATTER NARRATIVE,
SHE DID THAT NOTORIOUS BOW, GOT
DOWN ON ONE KNEE, AND WE ARE
GOING TO DO THIS AT SHOW THAT WE
ARE GOING TO HIRE A BUNCH OF
BLACK PEOPLE BUT WE DON'T
ACTUALLY CARE WHAT THEY THINK,
WE JUST NEED THEM TO SIT THERE
AND BE BLACK.
NOW THE BLACK AMERICANS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE ARE WAKING UP AND
GOING YOU KNOW WHAT, THAT'S NOT
OKAY WITH ME, AND THEY'RE
FRANTICALLY SEARCHING TO DRUM UP
A NEW IT NARRATIVE OF HATE AND
THIS ONE IS GOING TO BE
ASIAN AMERICAN, ASIAN LIVES
MATTER, QUICK, GRABBED ME K5 AND
HOPEFULLY AMERICA IS GOING TO
FALL FOR THIS WHEN IN REALITY,
THE GAS PRICES, THE INFLATION
PRICES THAT IT'S JUST AN
ABSOLUTE AND COMPLETE JOKE.
>> Tucker: IS THERE ANYTHING
MORE DESTRUCTIVE THAN WHITE
LIBERAL GUILT?
IT FEELS LIKE IT'S HURT MORE
PEOPLE THAN NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
>> IT REALLY HAS.
AND PEOPLE ARE STARTING -- EVEN
PATRICE COLORS, THE PERSON WHO
STARTED BLACK LIVES MATTER,
BASICALLY SAID IF NOT MY FAULT
THAT YOU GUYS GAVE ME HER WHITE
GUILTY DOLLARS AND I LIED ABOUT
WHAT I DID WITH IT AND BOUGHT
MYSELF AN ENTIRE REAL ESTATE
EMPIRE, AND THAT'S THE TRUTH.
IT'S NOT JUST BLACK AMERICANS
THAT NEED TO HAVE AN AWAKENING,
IT'S UP WHITE AMERICANS, YOU
HAVE TO STOP ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
MANIPULATE YOU -- HOPEFULLY
WE'RE GOING TO START TO SEE THAT
AS WE HEAD INTO THIS ELECTION
CYCLE.
>> Tucker: PEOPLE WHO HATE
THEMSELVES ARE NOT GOOD LEADERS,
WEAK MEN AND UNHAPPY WOMEN,
THAT'S THE DEMOCRATI